let's talk to Paula Abdul News and I
think this actually hurts you a little
bit Kelsey cuz you mind usin Paula I
just I'm the number one Paula Abdul fan
on the planet so it does hurt but not as
much as it may have hurt Paula Paula was
performing at a concert in Biloxi
Mississippi and as the 56 year old
walked toward the end of the stage to
greet fans this happened
don't worry Paula's rep tells us quote
Paul is fortunately not injured and was
able to continue the show in fact a
concert goer tell CT after the fall she
got back up never skipped a beat Paula
is currently on her first solo tour in
over 25 years
last year she told us it's not easy they
say it's like riding a bike
yes but 25 years later it's not as easy
I will say that but again it's a
challenge and and you know I went
through so many injuries that prevented
me from performing for the longest time
Paula had another minor concert mishap
this swept at Fenway Park in 2017 Paula
said to resume her straight up Paula
20:18 tour on Thursday in Canada
[Music]
[Applause]